within a thirty four hour period Donald
Trump on Twitter of course called the
entire Trump Russia hacking interference
collusion story a hoax while also
blaming President Obama for not
preventing Russia from meddling in the
election
Donald Trump has long called this a hoax
just to give you a sense here's a few
prior tweets from Donald Trump about
this issue for example Donald Trump once
tweeted the Democrats had to come up
with a story as to why they lost the
election and so badly so they made up a
story Russia fake news another tweet
from Donald Trump Russia talk is fake
news put out by the Dems and played up
by the media in order to mask the big
election defeat and the illegal leaks
again Donald Trump quote Russia must be
laughing up their sleeves watching I
don't even know what that means watching
as the US tears itself apart over a
Democrat excuse for losing the election
and then maybe most relevant for our
conversation today just a couple of days
ago June 22nd 2017 at 10:01 a.m. eastern
US time Donald Trump says the entire
Russian hacking thing is a hoax tweeting
why did Democratic National Committee
turn down the DHS offer to protect again
tax long prior to election it's all a
big dem hoax and here's the payoff June
23rd at 8:43 p.m. just thirty four hours
later all of a sudden the Russian
meddling is real but it's President
Obama's fault Donald Trump tweeting
quote just out the Obama administration
knew far in advance of November 8th
about election meddling and Russia did
nothing about it
why on Friday Donald Trump also said in
an interview on Fox News's Fox and
Friends that Obama quote
knew about Russia for a long time before
the election and he did nothing about it
so which is it Obama did nothing to stop
it or it never happened it can't
possibly be both and this is classic
disinformation it might be the result of
sheer stupidity
on the behalf of Donald Trump but this
is actually a tactic no one knows your
real position everyone can find one
instance of you taking a position that
they like or agree with and clearly it
works Pat because this is the type of
disinformation planned or due to sheer
incompetence that got Donald Trump
elected in the first place it's hard to
get inside the mind of Donald Trump but
I'm going to attempt it here please I
think what he means is that it's fake
news that that there was any collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
but the idea that they hacked the
election is completely valid and he's
even said things to this effect yeah but
he the guy has even rejected the report
of intelligence agencies saying that
there was was interference made weird
it's weird yes I mean well the lesson
here is that you can't really learn much
from 140 characters or less and it'd be
nice if there were some long detailed
press briefings where we can really
understand what the Trump administration
position is and yet I feel like those
140 character tweets of Donald Trump are
probably going to be discussed in
history classes in 50 years which is
really really scary but here's the
really disturbing part Donald Trump is
seeing all these intelligence reports
all the reports from our intelligence
agencies saying yes Russia hacked before
news outlets see them but because that's
the source of all of Trump's fake news
he seems to not believe his own
intelligence agencies until his selected
choice right-wing media reports on stuff
it's just very very odd and at the big
high at the highest level of disturbing
that Donald Trump seems to get his
intelligence from corporate right-wing
news rather than his own intelligence
agencies it's like after the first 100
days in office he ran that campaign
style ad yeah and he made all these
claims that were cited by media
organizations who he called fake news at
one point right at least so if you're
someone Trump likes you're the smartest
best person ever if Trump doesn't like
you all of a sudden you're a terrible
person and a liar the same news outlets
are either fake news if they put out a
story Trump doesn't like or Trump will
source you in one of his ads if he
happens to like what you said it's all
meaningless folks that's the takeaway